1.4 advantage quite a big advantage for
a niche
i mean here in this type of position i
think we would just discuss
grandmasters we would just say it's
easier to play with white white is the
one who can take the draw at any moment
if he wants black is the one struggling
and defending i'm not sure that will
translate into a kind of concrete
physical advantage in terms of winning
material or winning a pawn being plus
one up but it's definitely easier to
play with white okay okay but repeating
the position this is the second time
we've seen this position okay anish
needs to find a different square for the
white queen
ah i
if he takes the draw and then gets
eliminated i think he will live to
regret it so yeah he should keep the
queens on at least play on a bit longer
i don't think you will take the draw i
think we're safe though i think you will
oh has he taken a trial
really what okay magnus meanwhile
smiling a niche wow bailing out with the
draw he could have kept the game going
another 20 30 moves and then gone for
the same draw